port the claimant's of one the
government has lost the article 50 case
here in the High Court the claimants
have won this is an extraordinary legal
development few people expected this
when this court case was first given but
extraordinarily the High Court has
decided that Theresa May does not have
the ground prerogative to trigger
article 50 herself and that will see
what the remedy is it could be that he
suggests the remedy would be that
Parliament has has to come forward with
a bill has to pass a bill in the House
of Commons and the House of Lords before
her article 50 can be triggered now we
would suspect that the government will
appeal about this that has been the
presumption I'm not sure I'm not sure
that's necessarily the case I've heard
some ministers news out loud that they
might not they might choose to get the
legal apparatus going in order to try
and trigger article 50 by March but at
the moment they have lost so people will
argue is this the Lord's this the
judiciary being anti-democratic going
against the will of the people as
expressed in the referendum that's an
argument you're going to hear a lot
today others will argue that it's not
just about democracy it's about
democracy yes and the rule of law
there'll be huge arguments about this
now as it stands the law says that
Theresa May cannot trigger article 50
herself she needs Parliament to approve
it and I think that that will mean the
House of Commons and the House of laws
stay tuned for whether the government
will appeal and throw this up to the
Supreme Court in December for the mother
of all constitutional cases but a big
shock here and not if you were watching
sky news i have to say we did point out
that the Lord Chief Justice had said he
was baffled by elements of the
government's case but a shock I think
for many in Westminster that the
government has lost this case the
claimants have one will get more
detailed to you about what the actual
remedy is very soon extraordinary
development
here at the high court's with Theresa
May and the government losing